back here in our state holding police
officers more accountable
that's the goal of new legislation just
passed tonight by the nevada assembly
the bill brought up during the state
legislature's second special session
this summer
includes several changes this involves
limiting the use of chokeholds
orco mana has the details for us one
in a bipartisan vote saturday night the
nevada assembly passed ab3
the police reform bill it limits the use
of chokeholds and requires more
intervention and reporting when it comes
to use of force
incidents while some believe it's a good
step in the right direction
others say it's either too restrictive
or it's not good enough
there are 38 eyes for nays nevada
legislators prioritizing police reform
ab-3 effectively bans officers from
using chokeholds although lawmakers
clarified there are exceptions for
self-defense
i don't want to give the impression that
a chokehold could never be used
other key parts of the bill include
requiring an officer to intervene if
another officer uses unjustified
physical force and requiring that action
to be reported
mandating drug and alcohol testing on
officers who are involved in shootings
and allowing the public to record law
enforcement activity
assembly bill 3 in front of you is the
embodiment of what we can do better
in the state of nevada because if we
aren't moving forward
we're standing still which means we are
falling
behind metro police in support of the
bill as an agency
we're always looking to improve our
policy and and do
what's best practices across the country
others in law enforcement
in opposition why is it that suspects
that
die in police custody always end up on
the ground prior to their death
the answer is simple they resisted
arrest some criminal justice advocates
saying the bill only covers the bare
minimum
i could be for this bill but
unfortunately it is not strong enough
ab3 was discussed in the senate as well
but some had problems with the process
it takes a long time to really get a
good bill worked out
this has been rushed the bill passed
through the senate committee of the hole
and will now go to the full senate for a
vote
reporting in the newsroom orco mana 8
news now
of course